[Music]
all right let's move on Carrie
Underwood's surprise announcement
Mike and Isiah and I are absolutely over
the moon and excited to be adding
another little fish to our pond you said
you could say Carrie is crying pretty
tears of joy today Carrie made that
surprise announcement on Instagram
did you notice she's wearing a baby pink
jacket well fans speculate it's a clue
she's expecting a girl in 2014 Carrie
told ET it would be their dream to give
now three-year-old son Isaiah a little
sister we plan on having a girl I don't
know if you can do that but at some
points we'd really like that a source
tells ET that this pregnancy represents
a new beginning after quote a very
challenging year last November she
suffered a serious fall that required
around 40 stitches to her face the baby
news also comes days after Carrie came
under fire from fans for her Redbook
magazine cover story where she said that
at 35 quote we may have missed our
chance to have a big family
[Music]
the country star made it clear she won't
be taking a career break anytime soon
September 14th her new album drops she
also announced her cried 3360 tour which
kicks off next May that would only be
the few months after the birth
[Music]